I could see this being a new trend
belong with like a sexy bikini and stuff
like that my mom always wore prom gloves
while driving because they protected her
skin from the Sun as her arms were out
here growing up I'd be really excited
when I'd see these tins expecting some
delicious buttery cookies I'd open it up
and I'd see just a bunch of sewing
needles and spools of thread and pink
cushions
it's safe it's cute and round and it's
durable
these are super big visors mentok shield
your entire face from the Sun she keeps
one in the car to protecting people from
sun damage and also wrinkling you could
wear this while going on a hike
committing a heist my mom wears this a
lot when she's gardening it's so
versatile they would fill in a sock with
rice and microwave it and it's great to
use as a heating pad some daughters use
it for period cramps they're great for
stomachaches and back aches it's
basically a cure-all she would take my
old t-shirts and turn them into either
dish rags or floor eggs she can afford
she cleaned the sink she cleaned the car
in the washing machine she would cut it
down into little squares depending on
what she needed to clean up my mom and
dad taught me this when I was really
young
it's just wetting a paper towel and
putting it over some rice this allows
you to actually receive the rice it
tastes a lot better it maintains the
texture it's not as dry my mom goes out
a lot with umbrellas especially you like
two theme parks you see this a lot I
like swap meets grocery store shopping
picking up your kids Asian moms love
protecting their skin because they don't
want to look old you would think it's
raining but it's not it's only the Sun
now that you've seen some asian mom
hacks what kind of hacks does your mom
use